sponsored by God of War ha ha
[Music]
chorong David Lucy David I've invited
you here because I'm getting the band
Ratt back together Oh fantastic and I
figured what better way to do that than
to invite you to my dungeon where I play
God of War and drink tiny cups of coffee
out of weird mugs this is number four
correct I think in the chronology it's
like number eight but if you were to
look at the sort of the big three right
the sort of court of it yeah be the the
fourth so this one is an entirely
different sort of take on God avoid the
interesting challenge of this game is to
actually take a character things I think
you know and actually show that he has
more dimension this story is way more
intimate way more personal really he's
estranged to his son and that journey is
all about getting them alone together so
that they could figure out how to relate
let's kick it off shall we
this is the first special move you're
gonna get a runic special but your other
game you're gonna get a ton and you can
choose the ones you prefer to use whoa
so that's the get-out-of-jail-free card
right there you're gonna knock everybody
back he's disappointed oh why is he
disappointed it is what him ironically
because his son was not able to control
his anger
oh god isn't that the pot calling the
kettle black right you know what I'm
saying cray cray listen like a chill out
a second dude the apple doesn't fall far
from the tree so if you throw the axe
it'll actually sort of please the
character so you can actually throw the
axe free somebody in place and then go
take care of somebody else so a lot of
the common scheme is about kind of
creating opportunities and creating time
for yourself I read about this you got
the guy
right yeah that spot oh wow who's your
son yeah
the scribe unless he let you fire go
ahead and transfer you picked out those
Oh his arrows are not bad
can I try skip different kinds of arrows
too like yeah throughout the game you
actually find several different arrows
that will change up his playstyle have
you been training in the offseason
what's happening here I'm starting to
feel the character more as I'm saying
you notice the beard is right the red
tattoo starts here killer all right
those guys have just killed a fully
grown man you know what I mean
I guess he's sad about it I don't blame
them I've never killed a fully grown man
either okay I think that would be how
difficult experience right it'd be nice
to have a dude like Travis around though
if you did do that who could like hold
your head and look at you and be like
I've done this many times before like it
gets easier or something kid
this guy's like he's got a few little
tricks up his sleeve or lack of sleeves
excuse me ladies and gentlemen
okay run away run away run away run away
actually you can run away and go get
help
yeah why should do that okay go away
ah no health now you're screwed
fire oh you got it I got er three there
you go so now you can hit the [__]
punch
eat it fire monster I beat the burning
fire troll alright next chapter well you
see you get to play the next chapter but
I'm afraid the video does have to end
sometime for you guys to see the rest of
God of woman sheep pick it up on April
the 20th but David come on man hold on
hold on just a little stretching and
stuff just look at the power glove